there's new evidence that suggests
keeping your body physically fit can
also keep you mentally fit the new study
published in the journal Neurology shows
middle-aged women who were very fit were
eighty eight percent less likely to
develop dementia later in life our dr.
Tara Narula is a cardiologist at Lenox
Hill Hospital in New York good morning
good morning I know this study was small
but it tracked women over a long period
of time right it did and that's one of
the things that was unique about this
and really adds to the growing body of
evidence suggesting that Fitness
particularly in midlife may translate
into your risk of dementia down the road
now I want to be clear by Fitness we're
talking about things you cannot control
like age gender body size and genetics
but also how physically active you are
so in this study they looked at about a
hundred and ninety Swedish women who
were middle-aged they gave them an
exercise test they had them ride a
stationary bike for about six minutes
and then they group them into low medium
or high fitness they followed them for
about forty years to see him develop to
dementia and they found that those who
were in the highest fitness group about
5% of them develop dementia contrast
that with those in the lowest fitness
group about 32% developed dementia in
addition it seemed to delay the onset of
dementia so for a woman who was
considered medium fitness she developed
dementia at the age of 79 for those in
the highest fitness group 11 years later
at the age of 90 oh this is exciting you
had all Swedish women no 63 year old
black women no and unfortunately that I
just we did well this was a Swedish
study but it is the only night we need
more Studies on women of college yes we
do but yes there was only women it was
only Swedish women it was a small study
it's not a cause-and-effect study so
what do you think it it that heart
health
Abigail's question can it work for all
of us and no woman wants to get dementia
I don't know nobody are where you live
that's right and I think one of the
interesting things is trying to tease
out what is it that's really preventing
the dementia and so one of the theories
is that it's that you're controlling
your cardiovascular risk factors better
by having better fitness so you're
decreasing blood pressure you're
improving cholesterol blood sugar
obesity risk but in addition there may
be direct factors so you may be actually
changing the circuitry the wiring the
connectivity of the brain the actual
brain structure so there may be two
things going on
so you said Fitness though was Bo
the exercise but then all those other
things you can't completely so it is
both right but it doesn't mean that you
need to just say well I am you know
genetically blessed and I can forgo the
exercise the physical activity that you
do is part of it and we're not talking
about running a marathon you know when
we spoke to the researchers where they
said basically we're talking about a
moderate level of aerobic exercise and
what can we tell if anything about men
well nothing studies although the
researchers just say that they think
that this would translate you know into
the same effect for men but yes this was
only a study of women very good thanks
doctor thank you